[Music]
all right it's October 12th 2023 I'm
Dave ruin this is the Ruben report we
are live streaming on Rumble YouTube
locals all the usual spots if you want
to join us for the postgame show and I
want to welcome all our new subscribers
it's uh Ruben report. locals.com we're
going to just dive right into it today
obviously you know the world basically
just kind of continues to to spin out of
control and as I was talking about
yesterday and if you've seen uh part one
or the full version of my interview with
Megan Kelly which is up on locals
already uh you know this idea that the
the sensing apparatus of our country has
just absolutely failed right our
colleges and our universities have
completely failed and took young minds
and turned them into radical lunatics
look look at the protests happening at
so many of the universities our
mainstream media has lied to us about so
many things for so long that everyone
thinks that up is down and left is right
and boys are girls and all of those
things and the and the bad guys are the
good guys all of it right so it's in
some ways it feels very obvious that
we're here nobody nobody thought or I
guess I can't say nobody but it would
only be in someone's worst nightmares a
sane person's worst nightmares that
would has transpired over the last
couple days would be humanly possible in
the world 2023 and that human beings
would be capable of doing some of the
things that we are seeing um but here we
are and we better figure it's not only
that we have to figure out like the
difference between right and wrong we
better be able to figure out a way to
communicate that to each other because
this thing could continue to spin out of
control very very quickly I I do want to
address one thing up top related to some
of the pictures and images of the the
horor and the devastation um you know
we've shown some here I will continue I
don't know we're going to just figure
out a judicious way to do it that I feel
like is is right because we must be
witness to the horror um but I I don't
want to I don't want to do horror for
Horror's sake um but if we don't witness
it then we'll just kind of do it all
over again and that was the whole
purpose of never again at the end of the
Holocaust right so I think it's
important uh the Israeli government just
released some of the pictures of the
murdered and uh burned babies um if you
want to see it I I put it on Twitter
again just because people need to
understand that this is real and it is
happening and if you think it's going to
stop with the Jews uh well you probably
have another thing coming so anyway what
I want to get into today is a little bit
of the the media coverage on all of this
obviously some of the spats that are
happening on Twitter not because I think
the Twitter fights are important but
because I think moral Clarity is
important and even some people who I've
given some credit to over the last
couple years that I've done videos on
even in the last year uh are failing big
time right now and I'm and I'm happy to
say that a lot of people that I did not
um think would fail have not failed and
I just want to give credit uh quickly
and then we'll get into it to to one guy
uh Dan banino who has become a buddy of
mine you know it's funny we're so in the
same world together Dan and I have only
met twice despite all the stuff we've
done with r locals and all that we've
only met in person twice but Dan banino
put out a statement yesterday because he
has been so stalwart in his defense of
Israel and fighting the savagery and all
of this stuff and and a huge amount of
his audience is pissed at him really
angry at him and he basically just said
kiss off like I do not care and I can't
possibly I've met a lot of great people
doing this and I've met a lot of
grifters doing this I just want to
publicly I did it on Twitter but I think
it's worth saying what a great human
being Dan banino is and it'll cost him
money probably and sponsors and all all
of those things and I know he just
doesn't care and I would also connect
that to something that I've been talking
about a lot lately for the last month
which is audience capture that any of
the people that you watch including me
are susceptible to the idea that oh my
God my audience thinks this I better
keep giving them what they want right I
better keep giving them red meat so that
they don't leave me and I just simply
will not do that I as I said the last
couple days uh I've been jumping into
the comment sections everywhere and I'm
so thrilled to see so many of you uh
well so many of you are new viewers but
so many of you are just appreciative of
the way I'm trying to do this and that
is what I will continue to do uh so the
theme today obviously will be everything
that's sort of gone on and and the
Ridiculousness how BLM was connected to
Hamas and that's connected to the Hamas
caucus of AOC and ilhan Omar and the
rest of them uh how we get gen Z back
because we seem to have lost them and
they're the ones leading a lot of the
protests on the street and then about 20
minutes from now uh you know we had uh
Ambassador David fredman on the show
yesterday we had him come on in the
middle of the show and a lot of you
liked it and immediately when we end it
I thought man that's that's a way to
expand what we're doing here especially
in this crazy time and get more sobering
and clear voices out there actually uh
so John cardillo who is a good buddy of
mine and he is a former New York City
police officer uh he's a great analyst
on uh world events uh he's going to
chime in talk about what's going on in
some of the Western countries related to
security and and and a whole bunch more
so we'll get to John in about 20 minutes
all right here we go before we do that
though uh let's talk about Birch gold
group you guys know that Congress once
again allowed itself to be pushed into
appeasing the administration and raising
the debt ceiling for the 79th time
Paving the way for continued Reckless
spending and further devaluation of the
dollar as our national debt continues to
Skyrocket how are you protecting your
savings well guys Times Like These are a
great reminder to diversify a portion of
your savings into gold and you can do
that with the help of Birch gold here's
the easiest way Birch gold will help you
convert an existing Ira or 401k into an
IRA in Gold you don't pay a penny out of
pocket out of pocket and as bricks
Brazil Russia India China and South
Africa band together against the dollar
more and more central banks are
diversifying and of course yes they are
buying gold follow their lead visit
birchgold.com for your free info kit on
gold there's no obligation just
information they've got an A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau and
thousands of happy customers Birch gold
can help protect your savings too visit
birchgold.com
sdave and now back to me okay so again I
mentioned that I don't want to get into
these little Twitter fights about things
but you know I've played a bunch of
videos over the last year uh by Andrew
Tate Andrew Tate former kickboxer now
he's sort of become like this like men's
rights guy sort of
like I dare actually I was going to make
like the most sort of weird connection
to Jordan Peterson in terms of men
standing up for themselves but this guy
deserves no credit and I sort of regret
covering him at any level um he uh he's
a former kickboxer basically uh and uh
but he has made quite a name for himself
and built all sorts of businesses and
all that stuff um but he tweeted
something out uh just a few hours after
the attacks began on Saturday and I want
to just show you the difference between
sort of a conf a morally confused
opinion and then I'll juxtapose that
with something else and remember this is
just a few hours this is before Israel
did anything in Gaza or anything else
this is as as it was all unfolding
Andrew Tate tweeted out this is Israel
forced five vaccines into everyone's arm
forced rather live in Palestine and own
my blood Allah abbar um listen I have no
defense over any country that mandated
vaccines on anyone I think I've been one
of the most outspoken antivaccine
mandates uh mandate person people in the
entire country if not the world uh
Israel did force a lot of people to get
vaccinated and they have to deal with
that internally and what that means just
as our government does and and virtually
every government of the United States uh
but to somehow take that thing that all
countries did crazy things around coid
and combine
it with in the midst of beheadings and
babies being burned alive and everything
else a criticism of Israel again before
they had even done anything uh to Gaza
it is
absolutely insane it would be as if 911
happened if today the freedom Tower blew
up which you know I have no doubt these
people are planning if the Freedom Tower
blew up and then someone was like I
can't be for America because Joe Biden
mandated vaccines it is
absolutely insane um he lives in Romania
right now which by the way is a European
Christian Nation he happens to be Muslim
I mean I guess he could go to Gaza if he
wants but okay fine uh I want to get
into so Ben Shapiro responded to him but
I want to show you something else from
Ben Shapiro quickly uh the UN he
retweeted uh well you can see the lower
headline and then Ben Ben's response and
it's always particularly interesting
when I drop some f bombs I guess is
something but when Ben does it it sort
of has a little extra something uh just
in the UN special rapur for human rights
in Palestine we are horrified but what
is ha by what is happening and we call
for at truce Source Al jazer and Ben
said and they can right off and of
course Ben's um inclination there and
the colorful language there is correct
you don't know country literally no
country country on Earth would allow
what just happened and then do nothing
or do a proportional response or
anything else there's also no country on
Earth that when islamists murder their
people and like the
unpoke the horrific things that have
just happened any other country would
have full cart launch nobody would even
care right people it's basically no Jews
no news you know like that's kind of how
it is you could do whatever you want
somehow when the Jews defend themselves
it's a big problem anyway Ben said so
they can right off Andrew Tate then
responded so this is going to get us to
the to the wider thing here Mr tough guy
let me assure you as someone who has
done his own fighting as opposed to
excitedly encouraging others to do it
for him while sitting at home on a comfy
chair peace is always worth a
conversation uh before I get into what
Ben responded on that I mean it's just
meaningless dribble first off not
everyone is in the Army uh that is just
how it is we have people who speak for a
living and we have people who drive
buses for a living and we have people
who join the military for a living and
everything else we everyone is entitled
to their opinions on on things uh that's
just that's just an obvious position but
I don't see Andrew Tate going to Gaza
and fighting he seems to have no idea
what actually is going on uh why doesn't
he call for it right his initial
response was that Israel was evil
because of the vaccine uh Ben responded
and he wrote this let me assure you as
someone who has not pimped women and
bragged about it that morality requires
those who rape women and kidnap children
must be eradicated not negotiated with
and then something interesting happened
because uh Tristan Tate uh who is Tate's
brother he wrote this a Jewish man
speaking of a radication of a race of
people 2023 is a scary time to be alive
I wonder how many of the women and kids
who are soon to be obliterated kidnapped
uh to are soon to be obliterated
kidnapped or raped anybody my guess is
zero this is nihilistic and evil and
then Ben again because it's just
nonsense from these people he Ben said I
called for those who rape women and
kidnap children to be eradicated so you
are not only immoral you are apparently
illiterate yeah you have to understand
there's a very duplicitous thing that
many many people are doing right now and
the duplicitous thing is somehow that
anyone is is celebrating or joyous about
what Israel has to do in Gaza Hamas was
elected by the Palestinian people there
are no Jews or
Israelis in
Gaza they left Gaza in 2005 they built
wall they said hey forget it we want
nothing to do with you guys and by the
way when they left there also was no
blockade it was only after endless
rockets and digging tunnels under the
ground and all of those things happen
that they even put in the blockade which
by the way as we've discussed Egypt has
as well uh this concept somehow that is
that people are joyful over uh having to
respond is
absolutely insane it's absolutely insane
so one more from Shapiro on this he was
responding to to Tristan Tate
um either you are stupid or you are
morally illiterate Hamas literally hides
behind civilians there are current they
are currently texting civilians and
telling them not to leave Target areas
they put their military headquarters
under a hospital um so look I I said to
Phoenix before we started I I'm not
going to want to do these little back
and forth things but I I think it's
important to expose a bunch of people
that have influence and say absolutely
in what what do you think Andrew Tate
and Chris and Tristan Tate would do if
someone raped all of their hookers or
their mother or anything else like what
would their response be what would your
response be so all these people like
just sitting on the couch Tate's very
concerned Andrew Tate's very concerned
about people sitting on the couch having
opinions he's sitting on the couch
having an opinion telling people whose
babies have just been burned alive you
can you can go on my Twitter and look at
it if you want to see it burned alive
sit back and do nothing Gaza chose they
made a choice the Palestinians not only
did they elect Hamas Hamas then killed
all the oppos position they were running
an election against F they killed a
whole bunch of them you can find the
videos back in I I believe it was 2005
right after the disengagement they never
held elections again they are an avowed
terrorist group which by the way is
saying that they're calling for a day of
rage tomorrow for Muslims to kill people
westerners all over the
world that I suppose that might include
uh Andrew Tate or one of his prostitutes
who knows uh I want to show you video
this is uh this is Ben Shapiro last
night on Piers Morgan he was on Piers
Morgan right yeah it's on Piers Morgan
uh and he talks about his spat with Tate
and and basically just blows this whole
thing apart how did you engage with him
what do you feel about that well what I
feel about that is that he was tweeting
that immediately like as terrorists were
still running around in southern Israel
that was on October 10th and he was
still Tweeting while the bodies were
fresh and warm in the streets pie is you
cannot make peace with people who
murdered your children and burned their
bodies you can't do that I mean this
this rush to
Israel the murder happens and you
immediately say okay well guys now truce
now truce now ceasefire that is not no
State worth it salt no government on
Earth would allow this kind of insanity
no government on Earth and no government
on Earth would listen to nonsense about
how you immediately have to seek peace
with a group that seeks your direct
extermination again I I can't emphasize
enough Israel turned over the Gaza Strip
to gazans in 2005 Hamas has governed the
area since 2006 the year is currently
2023 Israel hasn't has in endured round
after round of Rocket fire on his major
cities for literally almost 20 years and
now the idea is the minute that gazen
that that Gaz and terrorists rush
through the border and murder people in
their beds that's the Time For Peace
conversation that's the Time For Peace
conversation by the way and I'm not
gonna be lectured on morality and
toughness by by Andrew Tate whose great
idea of toughness and morality is
pimping women and then bragging about it
on
air all right I know there's nothing
funny about any of this but you know I
got dressed today before I watched that
clip and Ben and I happened to be
dressed exactly the same way today I
don't know if that's if that's God
talking hey I'd like you guys defending
me to wear a blue shirt and a light gray
jacket or something of course everything
he said there is true and that he should
not be lectured about morality or
anything else um but but who else and
now I can get it to something wider
because again I don't mean it to be
about a spat about a former kickboxer
it's it's just these people and this is
from AOC and a whole bunch of people
that immediately it's like a whole bunch
of Jews get murdered in the in the worst
uh worst pgum since the Holocaust and
then immediately oh we should talk about
peace all of these people and I'm seeing
it I'm seeing it all over Twitter these
these people who can't figure out which
way which way the wind is blowing well
they're always going with the way the
wind is blowing but they can't ever say
stop I just pray for peace yes everyone
would like peace the Israelis left Gaza
for peace they literally left and said
we just want nothing to do with you guys
we tried Peace by the way they've been
offered the Palestinians have been
offered a state five times five times
and said no including at the very
founding of Israel the day before
literally the day before the war um they
can't make peace with people that want
to kill you if your neighbor every day
was trying to get over the fence and
throw things over the fence and trying
to shoot you and rape your wife would
you keep trying to figure out why he was
doing it or would you disconnect allog
together and and then of course you can
disconnect and they still try and that
kind of what got us here but who else is
in in the most most psychotic cynical
way uh siding with Hamas uh black lives
matter yeah surprise surprise the very
group that never did anything for any
black lives that never sent a young
black man to college that made a whole
bunch of people really rich that had the
entire corporate machine behind it well
black lives matter uh is fully standing
with Hamas this is a post that they put
up uh two days ago on the left that is
all that it is and it is a paraglider
and of course it was the paragliders who
parag glided into to that music concert
that executed 250 young people and they
use that as their image I stand with
Palestine and their statement is black
lives matter Grassroots stand in
solidarity with our Palestinian family
who are currently resisting 57 years of
settler colonialism and apartheid as
black people continue the fight to end
militarism and mass incarcerations in
our own communities let us understand
the resistance in Palestine is an
attempt to down the gates of the world's
biggest open air prison as a radical
black organization grounded in
abolitionist ideals we see clear
parallels between black and Palestinian
people so when ladies and gentlemen you
see these things and you read these
things and you look back on these last
couple years as this radical group
combined with antifa ransacked our
streets and destroyed property do you
know what they will do next and they are
here right now they are a domestic
Terror or organization uh they slightly
ever so slightly backtracked it in the
most cynical way which I'm not even
going to bother showing you their slight
retraction because they they're
borderline in legal trouble with that um
but I want to show you something that's
really fascinating because right now
Israel is obviously attacking Gaza they
are quite literally sending texts and
making announcements telling people you
have to move South you cannot stay here
because the more south they move the
closer to Egypt that they will be and
they'll the further away from Israeli
population centers where they just you
know murdered and slaughtered and raped
and everything else they are telling
people you must leave these homes and
then Hamas as Ben made a point of saying
Hamas is telling people no stay there
because they want the images to be of
dead Palestinians because Hamas doesn't
give a about dead Palestinians they
believe it's all part of the pr they're
happy to see dead Palestinians um but
the other piece that's happening right
now is Israel has shut off the water in
Gaza you know if you rape our women and
burn our children alive maybe we're not
going to give you you water you're going
to have to get water from somewhere else
so that's what they did that is a
decision they made and as I said they
have every right to do whatever the hell
they want to do right now uh and a lot
of people were very angry about that how
could they do that how could they take
their water away well then because these
people are throwing it in all of our
faces at every moment Hamas released a
video showing that they've been making
Rockets from the water pipes that Israel
gives them so that they can irrigate
their crops and so that they can drink
fresh water unbelievable watch
[Music]
this
I am not a fan of that song I don't know
who that is um yeah this is the open air
prison that supposedly everyone's
starving and it's a genocide even though
their population goes up every year
everyone's oddly wellfed somehow have
created an army all of those things
diving gear the scuba gear all that
stuff but literally it try to imagine
the the the the insanity of what is
going on Israel left and then the world
gave them money right the world said we
will rebuild Gaza and then they took the
infrastructure they took the cement and
the pipes made for water and everything
else and they turned them into weapons
of Destruction and now the same people
who gave the money and everything else
are telling Israel ah just let it go
sure your babies are burned let's just
let it go but the broader Point here is
that some people have been right about a
lot of this stuff and warning about it
for a long time and you probably don't
get the accolades or anything else but I
want to show you this really fascinating
video having having just told you what
BLM they BLM has staked out their
position think about the amount of money
that was given to BLM from our
corporations and from our our pathetic
limp
liberal Progressive buffoons who kneeled
in front of black people and washed
their shoes in the summer of love as
they burned down their businesses the
millions hundreds of millions of dollars
there is every reason to believe that
some of that money was funded to Hamas
at this point they are showing you hey
we are one we are one I want to show you
this fascinating video this is from
three years ago when Don Lemon was still
employed by CNN that's how long ago it
was and actor Terry Cruz who also I
would say happens to be black went on to
debate about the radicalism of black
lives matter take a look you say you're
willing to die on this hill You' taken a
lot of heat for this explain what you
are thinking uh and why it's so
important that you die on this
hill well again you know I want to bring
up the fact that you know there are some
very very you know militant type forces
in Black lives matter and what I was
issuing was a warning you know it's one
of those things where I've been a part
of groups I've been a part of different
things and you see how extremes can
really get can go far and can go wild
and if when you issue a warning and when
a warning is seen as detrimental to the
movement how can you ever ever have
checks and balances um you know in the
60s and 70s airplanes went down all the
time and the reason they found out why
they did was because the pilots could
never be questioned and when you have
the leaders of the black lives movement
who are now talking about you know if we
don't get our demands we're going to
burn it down uh other black people who
are talking about working with other
whites and other uh other races they're
they're being viewed as sellouts or
called Uncle Toms it starts starts you
start to understand that you are now you
know being controlled you're not being
treated as loved you're actually being
controlled someone wants to control the
narrative and I viewed it as a very very
very dangerous self-righteousness that
was developing that you know that that
really viewed themselves as better it
was almost a supremist
move I mean isn't that something there
were people calling out this nonsense
right it wasn't it wasn't just like the
political crew of people that could see
what was going on here right and US
hysterical YouTubers like guys something
ain't right here the people saying that
they for tolerance and peace are the
ones blowing apart buildings and you
know destroying small businesses and
everything else did you see by the way
the the Chiron that's the uh little
piece that they put under with the
guest's name it said Terry Cruz defends
his statement of uniting with good
people black or white as if that's a
controversial statement Terry Cruz hey
black and white people let's all unite
together let's fight the forces of evil
and blah blah blah blah blah but he's
kind of the the SC the the scary person
in the picture but now look at how
dangerous that radicalism the BLM
radicalism the identity politics
radicalism and and the Deep connection
it has we now know I mean BLM is saying
it to Hamas and what is now a genocidal
organization uh that apparently wants to
export that all over the United States
uh look what's going on right here in
the United States this is a pramas rally
pramas this is not for the people of
Gaza if you want them to live free this
is a pramas rally in Rashida talib's
District in dearb michig and this is
chilling this is chilling this is Nazi
1938 level stuff so don't let them get
it twisted this is not complicated when
you go to a black lives matter rally you
see Palestinian Flags when you go to a
white supremacy rally you see Israeli
Flags this is not complicated when
zionists March down the street they say
death to Arabs when we March down the
street we say free free Palestine free
free Palestine this is not difficult
everybody
what do you think those people would do
to their neighbors not I'm guessing not
many Jews in dear Bor Michigan but what
do you think those people would do when
you when you hear that there is a a call
or a day of rage tomorrow like who are
they talking to when they say do it all
over the
world I don't know also everything he
said there was complete nonsense uh
White supremist rallies that have
Israeli Flags first of I don't know of
any white supremacist rallies that have
happened in the United States like
within the last 30 years or so there's
probably a couple white supremacists
somewhere not great people there you go
we did it okay easy enough they carry
Israeli Flags oh and that the zionists
are chanting death to the Arabs no one's
chanting death to the Arabs and no one
ever does having been to Israel many
times all these people ever talk about
his peace the country is constantly at
war with itself over how to get peace
right like do we leave give them land
for peace do we not should we uh you
know have uh Commerce with them or not
like what do we they they just did it
again they shot more Rockets into us
should we have more peace like
everything they have done is in the name
of Peace everything they have done uh as
many people point out if the uh if the
Palestinians laid down their arms there
would be peace tomorrow if the Israelis
laid down their arms there would be a
mass genocide that is just so obvious
and everyone knows it imagine if the
power situation was reversed right here
what would be going on you all know it
everyone know knows it um and also this
you know so the the zionists shout shout
kill the Arabs or whatever and we shout
free free Palestine yeah that that is a
call for genocide right River to the Sea
uh yeah that means no Jews living there
so there you go um I don't know what you
have to do with these people we we are
going to be in a massive fight over free
speech in this country because at what
point you you can have whatever odious
views you want and you can get as close
to that line there's no such thing as
hate speech right I have defended hate
speech many times don't forget the ACLU
defended the rights of neo-nazis to
march in ski Illinois in 1972 ski
Illinois had I think the largest
contingent of Holocaust survivors in the
United States we always want to defend
all of our ideals but at what point when
a group of people in our own country are
defending a terrorist organization that
is literally calling for people to kill
people in our country at what point do
we have to have a different conversation
and again I would link this to what I
started with the show what I started the
show with we have so obliterated our
sense making Hamas basically as a
television channel on MSNBC we have so
few people who can analyze anything
honestly that it leaves us confused and
it leaves us basically unable to see
evil and know what to do about it
speaking of seeing evil uh here's a
video of AOC uh this is when she was
running for congress in 2017 and
listened to her moral confusion and
ahistorical nonsense I mean I think that
usually goes without saying when you're
talking about AOC like there in terms of
geopolitics and the war in midd East is
very different than people expressing
their First Amendment right to protest
well yes but I also think that what
people are starting to see at least in
in the occupation uh of of Palestine is
um just an increasing crisis of
humanitarian condition and that to me is
just where I tend to come from on this
issue you use the term the occupation of
Palestine M what did you mean by that oh
um I think it what I meant is like the
the settlements that are increasing in
some of these areas and and places where
um or Palestinians are experiencing uh
difficulty in access to uh their housing
and homes do you think you can expand on
that yeah I mean I think I'd also just I
I am not the expert on geopolitics on
this issue you know you all need to know
that America is not sending their best
and brightest you know to Washington
DC like sometimes sometimes you
literally just can't believe like you
know these people are making the
decisions that are you know determining
the the government here it's it's it's
actually
scary ah we did that for you it's been
heavy lately so we threw in John fedman
making a joke and speaking in a coherent
sentes Which is far more coherent than
anything AOC said right there she
clearly she is a godamn idiot
she has no idea what she's talking about
it is profoundly obvious the fact that
this woman is in Congress she doesn't
know what she's talking about an
occupation she has no idea what the land
is like or settlements or anything else
like the woman is a complete and utter
buffoon and that was by the way that was
what seven years ago so she's more
powerful now than she was then she
should have been laughed out of
H you get the point all right I want to
bring on John cardillo he is a very good
friend of mine uh former New York City
police officer clear-minded thinker he
gets it on the geopolitical issues and
on American Security and a whole bunch
more and he is a proud Floridian wisely
John you made the move from New York to
Florida what what was it TW 15 20 years
ago when did you come to the free state
of Florida yeah yeah this coming
February of uh 24 will be my 20th year
February 23rd of 24 I'll be here 20
years and I never looked back do do you
now in retrospect think boy I saw some
of the markers and and we can connect
this to The Wider conversation that
obviously everyone's having now uh you
saw some of the markers of what was
going to happen to New York City and
that how that's related to everything
that I've just spent you know the first
half hour talking about yeah absolutely
I mean look there was this General
malaise over the city after 911 and I
just wanted a bit of a change and I
thought I'd spend out 6 months or a year
in Florida I found an apartment in uh
the Brickle area Miami it's very
vertical right so when you come out of
Manhattan it's comfortable similar Vibe
and just the ability to do business the
ability to start a business was so much
easier I mean even as former law
enforcement the hoops and hurdles I had
to go through to buy new guns in New
York or carry a firearm tress to Florida
it was just a sense of Freedom you
didn't get pulled over if you you know
you got in your car you drove a block
without your seat Bel there weren't 47
law enforcement agencies pulling you
over about the seat Bel or your cell
phone you just felt it was an easy
easier place to live government laid off
they left you alone they did what they
were supposed to do and and not much
more than that so I know we could we
could talk about the uh the joys and
freedoms of Florida all day long but
that's that's not really what the thing
is this week truly um can you talk just
for as a former NYPD officer uh in the
Glory Days I can say of the NYPD because
it it ain't that way anymore a lot of
people are really worried right now
about what could happen in America
especially in our big cities and and in
the the degradation of our cities of the
police forces etc etc can you talk a
little bit about what police departments
maybe either should be doing or
hopefully are doing Etc yeah so the NYPD
actually has a very robust counter uh
terrorism operation and intelligence
operation so much so that the uh they
elevated them up to bureaus in the NYPD
which is really in terms of their silos
those would be the most significant they
would then sit alongside Troll and
detectives so they're a top priority
those issues intelligence and and uh
counterterror are top priorities the
other big agencies La Chicago Vegas
right it's a terror threat because of
Commerce and entertainment they're going
to be doing the same so the NYPD really
led the charge on this with regards to
the teams things like the Hercules teams
the atlas teams when you're out in New
York if you travel there I try to do it
as little as possible these but these
These are the guys and the helmets the
heavy vests the long guns there was also
a former senior Cia guy who came in
after 911 and really revamped the way
the NYPD looked at Terror looked at
intelligence and so they coordinate with
all of the federal agencies and people
may not know this but the NYPD has
detectives intelligence and
counterterror detectives deployed around
the world partnering with other agencies
in these nations very much like our
federal law enforcement have their ATT
and embassies and so in terms of Intel
for a local law enforcement agency the
NYPD is way ahead of the Curve and they
share that information uh pretty
seamlessly it flows very easily between
the NYPD and the other big departments
in the country they then trickle it down
to their states to their cities Etc in
those
States that's the way it's set up to
work Dave the problem are liberal
politicians in these cities who are
doing insane asinine things like cutting
the counter Terror Bureau of the NPD by
70% it's just mind-bogglingly stupid and
I had spoken to a couple of very good
mutual friends of ours who know a lot
more about the internal political
situations uh in Israel than I do and
they said unfortunately that sentiment
had also crept into the Israeli left
with regards to the IDF gun control Etc
I didn't realize until last week that
Israel now has strict gun control so uh
I hope what we're going to see as a
result of these atrocities if there if
one good thing could come out of this
horror hopefully it it smacks people in
the head and gets their heads on
straight to start being proactive about
the fact that there are evil demons in
this world typically Islamic terrorists
Muslim terrorists are at the Forefront
of that and start being proactive
against these people because my my fear
Dave is this I don't think we'll see
another 911 we we've got robust security
measures in place to avoid that but
there is virtually no way
whatsoever to interdict a lowtech
asymmetrical attack like seven bad guys
seven terrorists standing outside of
elementary school with automatic rifles
or walking in a shopping malls with
automatic rifles it doesn't take chatter
to set that attack up that John I
thought I thought that if you put a sign
up that says guns are not allowed here
this is a gunfree Zone wouldn't that
stop those people the sign because it
says it yeah of course you know because
you know gun laws apparently work where
the murder statutes don't right I mean
it's it's such a moronic mindset it's
it's as stupid as AOC was in that clip I
also want to somebody has spoken to this
about quite a bit offline and I'm so
glad you brought up Dan banino he's been
a good buddy of mine for years he also
worked in the NYPD during the Glory Days
and he has been such a Class Act
throughout the primary and with all
these issues and I just want to further
what you said about Dan and Hammer home
to your viewers uh just just how good
he's been on these issues and how much
Integrity he's had through all this look
there there are people that are really
shining right now and there's a whole
bunch of them we can't give them all
credit all the time there's a whole
bunch of people shining and then there's
a bunch of people who are having some
stuff shined on them but actually I want
to I want to show a clip of uh Governor
Dan santis yesterday because it'll get
us to our next part of this related to
the border and what you just mentioned
that this isn't like we're going to be
invaded by an army but what the hell is
going on on our border take a look I
would also ask the president to consider
reversing his policies on the southern
border we are vulnerable when you have
all these military age men coming in do
you think that our enemies have not been
looking at that weakness we know people
from Iran have come we know people from
Russia have come uh we know China and
other parts of the Middle East that is
not good for the security of this
country Israel probably has the
strongest border security in the world
and yet this happened to them well I can
tell you when I'm president we've
already said we are going to unleash the
States they're going to be equal
partners with enforcing immigration law
if someone comes across the river
illegally into Texas Texas should be
able to send them back why do we need to
end up in this big process where people
are going to court and all this other
stuff it's absurd
I mean that's basically why no one
wonders why we're proud to be Floridians
but but what do you think about that
part at the end there that he said that
the states need to be empowered because
I think a lot of people doesn't matter
what state you are in right now if
you're in America you've seen the videos
for the last month and a half of
thousands of people pouring across the
border we have no idea who any of these
people are their allegiances Etc what do
you think the states can do because you
know I'm we've discussed this many times
publicly and privately I'm not very
bullish on the national project of
America right now for a million Reasons
I'm bullish on some of the states but
can the states do enough once the border
is open the way it is yeah I think the
states can look when I watch Clips like
that of of Ron of Governor danis a guy
we both know and support I can't believe
every conservative in America every
Republican is not 100% behind this guy I
mean he first of all what he talks about
there isn't only doable it's absolutely
constitutional and it's immediately Dave
it's immediately Deployable it's not
some pie in the sky solution that will
take years to implement and sounds good
and can't get done it can literally be
done in the next 5 minutes while you and
I are talking States like Flor uh Texas
and Arizona have a very large
contingence of law enforcement state and
local county level agencies Arizona
where I spend a lot of time I in another
side of my life and and the real
business that pays me are OB scotdale
and uh I speak to Arizona law
enforcement all the time they are so
frustrated because they have the
resources they have have the knowhow
they know those rural areas they grew up
there these deputies these local cops
they know this the patterns of the uh
illegals coming across they could
Tonight Tonight make a significant DSE
if they were empowered by the federal
government all you've got to do if you
want to say okay immigration is a
federal function no problem president of
United States with an EO could federally
deputize every Deputy every police
officer in those States who can then act
as federal law enforcement and turn the
illegals back it is doable in the next 5
minutes so the governor is 100% correct
can you talk a little bit about the the
morale of the police departments and the
agencies I know you have a lot of
connections there as well because you
know having heard what you just said we
just know that it's not what Biden is
going to do right there could be an
attack tomorrow which they're telling us
there's going to be an attack tomorrow
and usually they do it when it's a
surprise not when they announce it but
uh that I would imagine the morale for
people that are like-minded that are in
the agencies cannot be good dealing with
such an incompetent group of buffoons
yeah you know it really depends where
they are right so when you talk to
deputies in departments run by
constitutionally elected conservative
Sheriff here in Florida they wouldn't
trade their jobs for the world if if
their if their true love is law
enforcement they love working in these
agencies because their bosses Empower
them they give them cover when they do
their job right but more importantly the
citizens want to see them they buy them
coffee when they go into a diner it's
very different in the big cities like
Chicago where they're being Spit On by
Muslim and hijabs and and the city
Administration isn't even allowing them
to make the disorderly conduct arrest so
it really is morale in in police
agencies around the country law
enforcement agencies really is dependent
upon the political leadership overseeing
that
agency I I suspect uh you don't see a
way at least for a little while that
that some of these blue cities will turn
this stuff around I mean I hope they
would you know take NYPD you the the
recently um departed Police Commissioner
she resigned Su everybody said oh she's
super woke and he hired a black woman
well she came out of the Nassau County
Police Department which is a large
agency right next door to New York City
for that's my County that's my hometown
County my whole family my whole family
lives out there except for my dad who's
still in Queens but um when I had called
a former uh uh command staff member of
that agency was very conservative I
asked his opinion he said actually she's
absolutely outstanding he said she's a
cops cop she's apolitical the cops
really liked her inside the NYPD but she
couldn't do anything because the
administration under Eric Adams and our
insane City Council in New York is so
far radically left they tied her hands
so she basically spent her time making
sure cops weren't getting in trouble for
doing their jobs properly and had enough
and resign well there are now rumors
that she wants to run for mayor I hope
she does because she's probably
electable as a black woman in New York
City and I think someone like that is
needed to turn things around I mean
Chicago went from bad to worse they got
rid of Lightfoot brought this lunatic in
and there went out of you know out of
The Frying Pan into the fryer it's never
been worse in Chicago so change in
leadership it's the only thing that's
going to do it let's just reverse back
to to some of the uh the actual what
we've been talking about all week going
on across the world uh because you
tweeted out saying that I thought was
really great I wish we would have pulled
it up maybe we can maybe they can grab
it for me uh that one of the first
things that you did when you were a cop
um C can you just describe the story so
I don't butcher it and maybe we'll grab
the exact language related to the rape
and murder and Yeah so basically I was
telling people to f off who were saying
oh you know we need proportional
responses I I one of the first when
you're a rookie police officer you get
the junk I said you get the details
right and you do you're the new guy and
everything's about seniority one of the
first things I had to do was sit on a
rooftop of a of a just a terrible
building in the Bronx with the body of a
raped and murdered 9-year-old waiting
for the medical examiner to come and the
crime seemed to be processed and special
victim detectives to do what they do
which is very exhaustive in a special
case when it's a child it's considered a
special case so the investigation is is
even that much more robust that much
more airtight and as the rookie you sit
up there and it is just I mean mentally
grueling and and you're thinking about
every baby you ever saw and every kid in
your family these IDF soldiers these
these families they're not seeing this
for four hours this is now their life
their reality and if it doesn't
infuriate you and if and if your
response is well you know it's not all
Palestinians there is there is
no daylight between Hamas and the
Palestinians and Dave nobody's ever
wanted the Palestinians pre- 1948 pre-
Israel when there were tons of
unoccupied Arab land around nobody
wanted them then asked Egypt how it
worked out for them this has always been
a terrorist culture so to those of us
that have studied this and and looked at
this with a pragmatic eye guys like me
like you like Ben Shapiro our friend
Josh Hammer over at Newsweek uh you know
we we know that this is is going to
happen again we were not surprised by
the viciousness by the horrific nature
of what these people people are doing it
uh so so for me when I saw those images
of children being burned and and hearing
these stories of children being raped
and I'm not doing this to be
Sensational we have to expose the
horrors people need to know how bad it
is it just brought that day back for me
and that was an example I had to use to
say hey if you haven't seen this you
don't know how bad it is let me ask you
one other thing which is the exact same
final question I asked former US
ambassador to Israel David fredman
yesterday what do you think a win for
Israel looks like right now complete
annihilation of every last Hamas
terrorist and profiling and monitoring
of every Palestinian for decades until
this insanely demonic behavior is forced
out of them I don't see any other way
forward demonic Behavior you know for
all the adjectives I've been using I
don't think I've said demonic I'm gonna
I'm throwing that one into the Lexicon
uh John cardillo I will see you in the
Free State of Florida I'm sure in the
next what you want to buy some guns next
week maybe we'll buy some guns next week
done absolutely guns and dinner Dave
they're on a perfect day in Florida
thank you my friend uh all right guys
we're going to uh we're going to
continue with just uh just a bit more
and I think we're just going to keep
doing this you know I said yesterday
this sort of mid mid interview we're
going to do it when we can to just add a
little context bring some some pros in
and uh get some fresh eyes on some of
the stuff I I want to show you a tweet
that I put up yesterday that really sort
of went went bananas viral on Twitter
and I think I guess it hit the right
tone maybe it's something you can share
or at least share the message of uh I
wrote to clear up any confusion for the
morally bankrupt who would Hitler be
rooting for right now thanks for playing
it's like guys we all know it we all
know it right like from from the gates
of hell that Hitler is in right now
right like he's watching this rooting
for for Hamas right he's rooting for
those dead babies and and all of the
rest of it so so let's go full circle on
today's show you know I try extreme in
good times I try extremely hard when I'm
talking about the nonsense of whatever
our
political chaos is and everything else
in the good times I always try to end on
a sort of positive note or give you
something to think about at the end that
will bring it all together or not leave
you feeling crazy about everything and
now we're not in the good times and I
still want to be able to do that
actually it's probably more important
now than ever so from Full Circle uh
from the the idiocy of AOC the
depressing of what has happened to gen Z
gen Z with these kids at these college
campuses putting out statements and
support of of Hamas uh from that
horrific rally that nail likee rally in
Dearborn Michigan and BLM and the
stupidity of Andrew Tate all of the
stuff maybe there's a way out of it and
who has explained a way out of it and
gotten more young people to deprogram
themselves than my good friend Jordan
Peterson well I think that if you set up
an education system that's designed to
do nothing but demoralize young people
and to convince them that their ambition
is dangerous and while even
world-threatening for that matter a
manifestation of patriarchal oppression
on the social front and then a danger to
the survival of the planet on the
natural front
then and you don't do anything to Foster
that ambition and to channel it into a
manner that might be productive and to
tell young people why their ambition
might be useful then you're going to get
exactly that so you hit what you aim at
if you try hard enough and the education
system has been trying to demoralize
people for 60 years then you think now
you have young people who are
demoralized and directionless well
they're never taught anything about how
to acquire a direction you know we did a
study I used this program I developed
called future authoring we did a study
where we had three studies actually
where we had University students sit
down essentially for 90 minutes 90
minutes this was it and write out a goal
a series of goals for their life right
who could they be in 5 years across
seven important dimensions of their life
and where might they be that would be
terrible if they didn't get their act
together we dropped their dropout rate
50% and raised their grade point average
30 by 35% three separate studies so
that's all you have to do if you want to
motivate young people is to teach them a
bit of visionary discipline and
encourage
it maybe that's what we got to double
down on right now maybe they're are
people who are smart enough and bright
enough and brave enough to help lead us
out of this desert and to the promised
land you think that that's possible
Right otherwise we will all wander for a
long time 40 years is a long time maybe
we don't have to do it for 40 years
right now but when you listen to someone
tell the truth and talk about how the
systems have failed all of the young
people right it's why every time I show
you one of these purple haired kids
scream or something it's like it's like
I'm not they're they're the victim of
this thing right these kids that that
are out there these these gender queer
kids that don't know what is what
they're that are now supporting Hamas
it's like they're the tools they're the
Rubes there's the they're the Pawns in
this game and we've needed more and more
people to stand up and tell people what
is right and that is the ultimate irony
related to our mainstream media because
the New York Times put Jordan Peterson
and me and a bunch of Ben Shapiro and
Milton Friedman and a bunch of others on
the front page once not too long ago
saying we were the head of the allright
the New York Times did another piece on
Jordan Peterson front page about he was
going for enforced monogamy as if he
wanted to enslave the women uh enslave
women the way islamists do so the entire
machine has been designed to destroy all
the good people and push up all the bad
ideas thus we are
here uh we will end with something funny
right we are ending the call oh yeah
yeah yeah we got a great cold close for
you you might have seen the movie we'll
get to that in just a second uh if you
want to join us for the postgame show
right now Ruben report . locals.com and
part one of my interview with Megan
Kelly is up on uh Rumble and on YouTube
the full thing's on locals already and
obviously we get into all of this and
you know Megan is just on the short list
of people that I can turn to for some
sanity besides Jordan uh so she gives
great analysis on this and it's really
been wonderful this week uh tomorrow
we've got a round table with uh Michael
nolles from the daily wire and Andrew
claven from the daily wire and we're
going to get into all all of this stuff
and now a Cole close I promise you're
going to smile and we'll see everybody
at the post game to be used for peaceful
purposes it will be used only for
medical research and clean energy it
will it will and will certainly never be
used to attack is oh
[Music]
boy
for